la lutte contre le coronavirus entravée
par la méthodologie des pays les plus
riches la mortalité dans ces grottes
dans ces grandes puissances
pousse-t-elle en effet à s'interroger
alors peut-on vraiment arrivé à la même
conclusion que le professeur de
marseille c'est l'objet de notre face à
face et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec patrick mennucci conseiller
municipal ps de la ville de marseille
bon soit patrick mennucci merci d'être
avec 6 à ses côtés à distance bien
évidemment jean philippe delsol avocats
fiscalistes et président de l'institut
de recherches économiques et sociales
bonsoir à vous aussi
alors ce constat soulevées par le
professeur raoul les pays riches qui
auraient plus de mal à mener la guerre
contre le virus en rien les précise le
professeur pour étayer son propos que
dans 15 pays qui ont la plus forte
mortalité
ce ne sont faites que les pays riches
que vous inspire ce constat vous
commencez par vous patrick mennucci
écoutez on entend beaucoup de choses sur
tous ces sujets moi je crois que les
pays riches sont souvent les pays
démocratiques etc que dans les pays
démocratiques il est plus compliqué de
lutter contre les virus on voit bien les
pays où elle a le sens de la démocratie
n'est pas exactement le même que chez
nous qui peuvent imposer des choses qui
sont difficiles pour les gouverneurs
france et des pays européens est imposé
donc pour l'instant je crois qu'on en
donne beaucoup de choses moi j'ai plutôt
j'ai toujours eu une très grande
confiance dans la science et j'avoue que
je suis un peu déboussolée d'entendre à
longueur de deux chaînes de télévision
et radios des médecins se contredire sur
ce sujet c'est extrêmement inquiétant il
faut bien comprendre et vous vous jeu
parce que vous êtes tous les uns et les
autres bains dans ma situation à mort et
avoir beaucoup plus de certitudes que
nous avons malheureusement on a là vont
pas et donc nous sommes amenés à suivre
les directives du gouvernement et
notamment la question du coffee damon
qui a quand même permis de limiter la
pomme demi heure parce que
malheureusement nous savons pas grand
chose sur cette épidémie
jean-philippe delsol vous ce constat
pour revenir au postulat de départ les
pays riches qui auraient plus de mal à
amener la guerre contre le virus patrick
mennucci nous dit plus compliqué
toujours d'imposer des choses dans des
démocraties vous partager ce constat en
partie je pense que si on prend
l'exemple qu'ils aient beaucoup donné en
ce moment du vietnam par exemple
j'aurais deux observations
la première c'est que c'est un pays
encore communiste et donc tout ce qu'on
nous dit dessus il faut s'en méfier
parce que on l'a bien vu avec la chine
les communistes sont par définition
donc prudence j'en garde totalement la
responsabilité mais enfin l'exemple
chinois est là pour le démontrer
deuxième observation dans un pays qui
est une prison comme le vietnam met
encore en partie bien entendu c'est plus
facile de dire à chacun de rester dans
sa cellule et c'est là que je rejoint
d'une certaine manière ce que disait
patrick mennucci mais avec des propos
peut-être un peu plus vif et plus
illustres et j'en conviens je crois que
d'une manière plus générale il est sans
doute difficile de tirer des conclusions
aujourd'hui oui peut-être que par
exemple aux états unis on aura plus de
morts parce qu'à plus d'obèses c'est
très possible
c'est l'une des options mais je crois
qu'on ne peut pas aller plus loin
aujourd'hui alors écouté avant de faire
réagir patrick mennucci didier raoul qui
était un petit peu son son propos
justement il évoque le traitement de la
maladie
dans les pays riches écouter tous les
pays riches et tous les pays développés
ont eu des succès beaucoup moins
important que les pays pauvres qui est
assez raisonnablement ont choisi de
traiter ça comme une boni avec des
médicaments banale qui ne coûtait rien
et qui ont du coup des mortalités
beaucoup plus faible et dans les 15 pays
qui ont la plus forte mortalité sané
coût des pays riches pour c'est à dire
qu'il ya une déconnexion actuellement
entre la richesse et la capacité à
répondre à des situations de cet ordre
là moi peut-être que j'étais capable d'y
répondre parce que je suis en partie
africain donc c'est une partie de mes
origines qui me laisse l'idée que l'on
doit traiter les maladies infectieuses
alors on va essayer de décortiquer ces
propos mais en clair c'est ce qu'il
disait tout à l'heure on l'entendait
dans le son précédent en gros ils vont
droit au but
ils prennent vont à des traitements qui
existe déjà
alors que les pays plus industrialisés
souffrir et peut-être de trop de
réglementation de trop peut-être de
précaution patrick mennucci a un petit
peu du but vrai l'un d'eux sort
je voudrais d'abord préciser que j'ai
beaucoup de respect parce que plus dans
les moments que nous vivons mais il a
soigné avec succès ma vieille tante et
je lui en suis très reconnaissant de
l'avoir fait aviez eu à part ça et je
crois qu'il ya effectivement avec
beaucoup d'humanité traiter tous les
marseillais qui ont pu être hospitalisé
[Musique]
je suis pardonnez moi de vous couper
mais votre expérience parle ça veut dire
qu il la traitait avec de la chloroquine
détail familiaux mais c'est une personne
que 82 10 heures l'acquittement de ma
mère qui elle est décédée et
évidemment pourquoi insister auprès de
l'ap-hm pour cuillé des hospitalisations
parce que il y avait tendance à ne pas
hospitaliser personnes trop pagis est
scandaleux qu'un délit sont disponibles
pour régler cette question et elle a été
traitée effectivement à la halle hydroxy
corps et qu'il est
voilà le san et senti à l'aise en prix
négatifs j'espère que ça va durer
comme vous le savez c'est une maladie
extrêmement complexe donc on peut pas
tout bien fait ce que je voulais en
revenir à votre question je disais ça
parce que je veux qu'on comprenne aussi
le il ya aussi les sentiments humaines
qui sont ces affaires-là dans une
pandémie ya des morts et il ya donc bien
des des histoires personnelles qui sont
celles des uns et des autres et de ce
qu'y que vous recevez du sur ses
plateaux qui ont une vie aussi peu par
ailleurs et moi ce que je crois le pied
dans ce que dit didier holt ces cas que
les pays dont il parle et je suis
d'accord avec monsieur del sol ce sont
des pays qui ne disent pas la vérité sur
la situation soit qu'ils ne le disent
pas pour des raisons politiques par les
viêt nam partage ce qui vient d'être dit
sur la nature du régime ou la chine
il n'y a pas de doute là dessus ou qui
n'ont pas les moyens scientifiques de
faire les recoupements et de données et
des statistiques à tommy que tel pays je
n'incite ok mais africains auraient
moins deux morts un pourcentage que la
femme c'est l'italie l'espagne ou
l'amérique je serais quand même curieux
de connaître les protocoles
scientifiques de l'addition des
personnes qui ont été atteintes
s comme c'est si c'était le coroner
voilà je crois qu'il ya des biais nous
nous devons être extrêmement prudent et
je crois que si on veut être honnête
avec ce que nous savons est ce que nous
sommes
il faut être très humble dans les
affirmations
alors jean philippe delsol rebondit sur
ce que disait patrick mennucci m'enfin
au moment où on dit ça faudrait que
finale times lui accuse les autorités
britanniques en tout cas pas accuse mais
en tout cas dit que le bilan est
largement sous-estimé le financiel times
pense qu'il y a deux fois plus de morts
donc c'est la panacée également des
démocraties peut-être de ce jeu met des
guillemets trompé sur les bilans liés au
courant navires us à ce qui est vrai
c'est que le gouvernement de monsieur
mac on nous a trompés pendant un moment
en nous donnant un nombre de morts
chaque jour qu'ils n'étaient que le
nombre de morts en hôpital donc
effectivement c'était très trompeur bon
ceci dit les choses ont été rétablies je
ne veux pas les accuser d'avoir fait ça
totalement sciemment ils l'ont fait dans
la précipitation
pour en revenir à votre sujet je pense
qu'ils voulaient que normalement c'est
vrai que les pays pauvres ont moins de
moyens
ils ont des techniques plus
rudimentaires ils ont moins d'argent ils
devraient donc avoir plus de difficulté
à combattre une épidémie d'autant que ce
sont souvent des pet shop a toujours pas
souvent dans lesquelles les gens vivent
plus grande promiscuité et donc on se
pose cette question vous nous avez posé
pourquoi est ce que semble qu'ils les
pays riches
au contraire on plus de personnes
frappées par il est vraisemblable et là
je rejoins didier raoul il est
vraisemblable que eux si nous n'avons
pas su donner une bonne réponse très
rapide
en dépit des moyens de la richesse cette
attaque nous avons dû développement
qu'elle nôtre c'est probablement parce
que nous devenons un peu comme les
dinosaures
vous savez on dit que les dinosaures
sont morts parce que il était devenu
tellement grand tellement gros que quand
un serpent mortels les piquets à la
queue il n'avait pas le temps de réagir
parce que la tête ne le comprenez que
trop tard et est en fait les pays riches
beaucoup d'enfants en tout cas et
notamment les les pays centralisé comme
la france mais pas que leur france
d'ailleurs
et les pays qui n'ont pas qu'ils sont
hervé à l'égard de l'économie de marché
c'est à dire aller cas à l'égard de
l'économie privée
ces pays là sont des pays qui en fait
pense que la seule solution c'est l'état
c'est la centralisation et d'ailleurs je
me souviens que monsieur macro le le 20
21 ou 22 mars sera le jour où il a
annoncé le confinement
il nous a dit à regarder c'était son
discours là enfin on comprend que on a
la chance d'avoir un état fort et et
d'un état qui fait tout et bien
justement on s'est aperçu qu'on avait la
malchance d'avoir un état trop fort et
d'un état qu'ils faisaient trop en fait
l'état ne sait pas tout faire il faut
qu'ils sachent qu éventuellement
coordonnées éventuellement s'assurer que
les choses sont faites fixer les limites
mais ça n'est pas à lui de tout faire
quand il veut tout faire il fait mal la
preuve c'est que en fait il n'a compté
au départ et on a pris beaucoup de
retard au départ pourquoi parce qu'il
n'a compté que sur l'hôpital public les
les hôpitaux privés associatifs souvent
les cliniques privées
oh c'est très vilain des cliniques
privées ya des capitaux privés vous
rendez compte ce que ces vilains
méchants
forcément c'est des gens qui ne pensent
pas à la santé des gens ils pensent
qu'on profite ben non et en fait c'est
une mauvaise réaction est donc en ne
comptant que sur le pilat public en
refusant l'aide des hôpitaux privés qui
avaient beaucoup de lits de réanimation
offert pour accueillir des patients et
qu'on refusait on a préféré faire venir
l'armée allait en allemagne en autriche
ou en suisse pour y apporter des malades
alors qu'ils avaient des lits vides
délit qui attendait les patients vous
voyez un exemple du scandale français de
l'étape trop fort de l'état obèses ont
dit que les obèses attrape plus
facilement le virus et bien je crois que
l'état centralisé trop important il
attrape trop facilement le virus de la
puissance est manifestement il y à là
chez nous un état malade de ce virus de
la puissance après je crois que c'est ça
a été la difficulté rencontrée deux
reconnus cette difficulté à réagir
on est en train de rattraper parce qu'à
la fin on a des gens intelligents
on a eu la chance d'avoir un personnel
extrêmement dévoués dans les
établissements sanitaires qui a compensé
les défauts du système mais je crois
qu'il faudra en retenir la leçon
patrick mennucci la réponse est
rapidement s'il vous plaît qu'est-ce
qu'on arrive malheureusement la fin de
sa vie mais je pense que m del sol
utilisant fait utilisé dans un
environnement et celui des pandémies et
il poursuit dans cet environnement de la
pandémie ses positions politiques que
nous le couple lui connaissons depuis 42
ans donc il essaie de démontrer que
c'est parce que les tailles propre
réserve que nous avons des difficultés
moi je suis plus de mon père et je crois
que il ya des erreurs qui ont été faites
que ces erreurs on les combat c'est le
manque de masquer ses serrures bonne
dissipation mais que quand même
globalement les décisions qui ont été
prises par l'état et notamment par le
service dans les services hospitaliers
alors moi je suis absolument pas
d'accord avec m del sol quand il dit
qu'il aurait mieux valu mettre des
malades terme les dans des cliniques
privées plutôt que de les envoyer en
allemagne saleh je connais bien et les
élus du blues et je peux vous dire que
les gardiens ont été en moyenne
allemagne il ne pouvait pas aller
ailleurs que dans des armoires
extrêmement pointues on pouvait sauver
terre et son épouse ont été pour la
plupart ils ont été pour la plupart
d'ailleurs heureusement pour eux grâce à
dieu peut tenir
saurik demande finistère est ce qu il
faut faire attention
la pandémie sera l'occasion pour
beaucoup d'idéologues comme les monsieur
del sol mais ce n'est pas une critique
c'est une constatation d'utiliser la
pandémie pour justifier leur position
politique moi je suis beaucoup plus
pragmatique et j'essaye d'être plus
ouverts au pouvoir
kiki ceux qui s'expriment parce qu'il y
aura un après et je ne crois pas que
cette a pris soin écrit dans le
libéralisme et on en reparlera ensemble
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
patrick mennucci jean-philippe delsol
d'avoir est pas très correct mais pardon
ça ne paraît pas correct que vous ne
laissez pas de cendres secondes oui
alors je suis désolé malheureusement
voilà c'est on arrive à la fin et voilà
on est jeune c'est court je vous promets
que vous aurez l'occasion de répondre
voilà vous avez répondu il vous a
répondu sinon en finir et on arrive
malheureusement on a des contraintes
antenne ça serait pareil sur une autre
chaîne jeunesse est exactement avec
votre plaisir c'est une promesse
contiendra puisqu'on arrive
malheureusement à la fin on a des
timings voilà c'est ainsi
malheureusement
merci en tout cas jean philippe delson
et patrick mennucci portez vous bien
tous les deux aussi voilà et on
continuera steva c'est promis merci